congrats on getting nominated for an
NAACP image award this show is also
nominated how does that make you feel oh
oh I'm I'm grateful I'm grateful uh to
the naacpe uh Awards and uh yeah yeah
it's uh my one of my first nominations
and uh I feel great about it
I mean I can only imagine how you felt
that first season
doing a reboot of such a beloved series
obviously there's expectations there's
that pressure you guys knocked it out of
the park season two did it feel
different going into this season filming
season two when you do when you do
things twice people always have
expectations you know what I mean and so
and so I you know I try to let that go
and just and just show up in the most
authentic way possible like we're not
gonna strike again the same way season
one struck right and so like we have to
find something different like the heart
is still there right but like we have to
be okay that it's not gonna be the same
and uh and I was okay with that right
and so like once once I let that go then
the magic happens the magic shows yeah
so speaking of
speaking of magic happening Tatiana Ali
on the on set season two what was that
magic magic she's amazing she's such a
sweetheart and she showed up and she was
so prepared and uh just just seeing that
mirror between like oh gee Ashley and
new Ashley like it's it was amazing and
I think fans are gonna be super excited
yeah did you try to control how much you
were geeking out did you want to ask her
stories about what it was like on set of
Fresh Prince like how much did you ask
questions oh I geeked out we geeked out
in a major way and she was okay with it
like I'm not afraid to geek out I'm like
yeah I'm a fan so tell me what happened
season two episode five of Fresh Prince
the original because I noticed that you
had changed your hair in that one scene
like that's amazing yeah yeah that's so
much fun and she seems so open and warm
which is really cool and she loved how
you guys all knocked on her trailer she
felt like really welcomed you guys were
all there together kind of welcoming
we're on set yeah I mean we have really
cool cultivated a family feel and I know
they did on the original as well and so
like the fact that our family is is
mixing and mingling with their family
it's so special such a special feeling
and and she was crying like she cried on
set because like it was like such a
surreal moment for her to be back right
you know and so because that was such a
huge part of her childhood and so like
so the the fact that she could share
that with Akira you know is is so
amazing because Akira is going to grow
up on our show so it's like it's such a
special thing I mean I can only imagine
you know the emotions that were going on
with her but she only had wonderful
things to say about the whole cast and
the show I was just talking to Adrian
Ollie and Jimmy and I was asking them
who do you think is the most like their
characters on the show and they said
you're the most like will me yeah yeah
yeah I guess they're right I think
they're right yeah yeah I am I am the
most like will I mean I mean our stories
are super similar like you know what I
mean and so like I think
you know my whole life people have been
like you you kind of resemble well in a
way like your energy is very well-ish
and I grew up watching the social I
think it's just embedded in me you know
in a way that's uh in a way that's
that's very authentic hi Tatiana how are
you hello I'm great how are you I am so
excited to talk to you I love your
revealing season two in the classroom
and then you turn around I just want to
know when was this in the works how did
this all happen
uh I you know how did how did this all
happen not not unlike other acting jobs
that I get
um I think they were already filming uh
filming the season and I got an offer to
play a character called Mrs Hughes and
uh I've always kind of thought of
Bel-Air as very much its own show and
you know very different from Fresh
Prince in many many ways and first
season they just ran with it and did
such incredible work and so
I was excited to see what they offered
me and then when I saw that
um Mrs Hughes the character I play you
know all our scenes she's a mentor to
Akira to Ashley played for by Akira
um Akbar I was uh
yes
I'll do it yeah it was very exciting
she's really well written yeah
um you know obviously Will Smith is an
executive producer on this did you get
to speak with him before coming on or
while you were shooting
uh no I did
um one of the days that I was shooting
um other members of the cast They had
just gone on to set around lunchtime and
I heard all this like on my trailer
they're banging really loud and um I
opened the door and it's like most of
the cast and they're like welcome you're
here you're here so we took pictures and
like you know stupid videos and I did
send them to will and I said I'm having
the time of my life this is awesome oh
amazing were they asking you for stories
what it was like when you were on set of
Bel-Air yeah we talked about
um
but I mean we shared stories we talked
about you know their experience
um
um it's it's a lot to have in common
with with people you know with a group
of a small group of people yeah
you know the Fresh Prince of Bel Air was
just obviously as you know such an
iconic show I'm sure people still to
this day come up to you want to know all
about it want to tell you how much that
show meant to them is there an iconic
storyline in Fresh Prince that you think
would be really fun for this Bel Air to
to kind of give their own spin on
hmm
I wonder if they've done this
I wonder if this I remember
an episode where
they might have played with these themes
a little bit but it's a famous episode
where
um will and Carlton are driving the the
uh Uncle Phil's Partners Mercedes-Benz
from LA to Palm Springs and they get
arrested
and
um
you know they get arrested they get
thrown in jail it doesn't matter that
they have driver's license it doesn't
matter that they have permission to be
in this car
um and and I remember as a child
watching you know watching us watching
them film I remember James Avery as
Uncle Phil going in there using his you
know legal kind of mind and stature to
to rescue his his
um young black boys from being
mistreated which is what was happening
and I remember you know it's a sitcom so
the joke was Vivian comes in and she
takes off her earrings she sells you
know hold this and
um
you know that's the thing about Fresh
Prince and I think what the one of the
things that they've captured in Bel Air
is that there's a timeliness to it so
well that's like a a humorous thing now
um
things that have happened recently don't
make that as humorous that to me is one
of those episodes that really stands out
and I don't think they need to recreate
that I think they're doing a really good
job of of giving it that sort of
cultural
um relevance are there any story lines
or any episodes that stand out to you
from the original Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air that you would like Bel Air to
kind of put their own spin on
actually I think you brought up like the
police when they got pulled over yeah
when they got pulled we got pulled over
by the by the cops and stuff I think
that we could definitely uh play on that
for this generation for sure and I think
there's there's something about that
that I I'm very excited for when we do
tackle it's going to be yeah it's we'll
get into it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Bel
Air fashion you know yeah and um I I
think um
or you know what we've done really well
there are a lot of iconic moments from
the original and we've done really well
in terms of not going there but doing a
subtle versions where people are
actually uh when Lou turns up you know
that reminds me of the original and uh
and uh and I think that's that's been
intentional It's like because this this
is a different show you know we're not
going to see the Carlton dance you know
we're in a different climate today as
well so we are we are our show is a
mirror of the of the climate of the
world that we're in today